[Music]
hi and welcome we're here at the
security zone and next with Sam Lu Ghani
an expert in phishing attacks at Google
cloud hi you Fang happy to be here
so phishing attacks are becoming a huge
problem today at companies aren't they
yes they are phishing attacks are a very
common type of security attack in fact a
study conducted by Fishman showed that
91% of cyber attacks start with a
phishing email Wow so phishing is one of
the main ways that security attackers
will attack companies yes that's what's
for an example let's say that an
attacker is targeting your company and
you're the security admin responsible
for protecting your organization so the
attacker is gonna start by doing some
research on your company on LinkedIn
where they can make a list of employees
that they want to target the attacker
then sends personalized emails to these
employees trying to get them to click on
a link or respond with sensitive
information so what happens if an
employee opens one of these emails or
links well let's find out let's say you
are one of the employees that's being
targeted with this phishing attack and
you are going to go through your inbox
in the morning on the screen here you're
gonna see some emails come up and you
have to choose whether you think the
email is a phishing email or a safe
email okay I think I can handle this
oops that was a phishing email it's hard
to notice but you can tell by looking at
the email domain in the from field so
what happens if I miss a phishing email
like this well if you respond to the
attackers email or click on a link in
the email you may end up giving the
attacker access to sensitive data let's
try another one
well done you've spotted a phishing
email how could you tell oh this URL
domain name looks suspicious right good
spot details like this are easy to spot
if you're looking for them but as you've
seen when you're going through your
inbox and try to work you don't have the
time to look at these little details and
emails right and I can't train all my
employees to go through each email in
detail to spot phishing emails you just
got one of two right which isn't too bad
but a report from Intel security on
phishing attacks showed that 97% of
users are not able to identify a
sophisticated phishing attack but
luckily if you're a security admin you
have a few tools at your disposal the
first tool is Gmail Gmail uses the power
of billion-plus user community to
protect against phishing attacks as
emails come in to your Gmail inbox they
will automatically be scanned to
identify phishing emails and if the
phishing email is detected is discarded
before hitting the users inbox but these
emails are often very sophisticated and
difficult to spot
so Gmail now uses machine learning to
identify patterns across messages this
allows Gmail to identify suspicious
emails that the ml engine says have a
high probability of being a phishing
email Wow so with machine learning Gina
is finding patterns in phishing emails
from billions of users and using that NL
model to identify emails or the high
phishing score or prediction yes exactly
so as attackers launch more phishing
attacks Gmail is learning from those
attacks and getting smarter and
defending against them so with Gmail
most phishing attacks either don't hit
you my employee inboxes at all or these
emails are sent with like a warning if
they're suspicious yes that's right
Gmail protects your employees from
having to worry about scanning each
email manually for phishing attacks
so is Gmail all I need to stop these
phishing attacks Gmail is the first line
of defense and is essential for
preventing phishing email attacks but
you also need a way to protect against
phishing websites and stolen passwords
which is by Gmail works hand-in-hand
with firm browser and tightened security
key is to provide end-to-end phishing
protection for your company
well Sam thank you so much for showing
us how companies can defend against
these attacks with Google cloud my
pleasure
you
[Music]